foreign
[Applause]
audience tonight in New York City by the
way we'll take questions you and the
audience get the last word tonight at
the end of the show also our Great
American panel is back and they'll have
reaction to What has been a very very
busy strange bizarre crazy Newsweek a
lot of hypocrisy on display and without
a doubt Democrats the mob the media they
are in quite a predicament now tonight
they have spent the last several months
breathlessly hysterically endlessly
demanding that former president Donald J
Trump be indicted and thrown in jail
over claims that he mishandled
classified material now we have a major
major development a little bit of a
problem for those Hypocrites their Buddy
Joe I don't know what day it is Biden
has been caught red-handed mishandling
top secret classified documents that he
apparently stole from the Obama
Administration now the sensitive
material was recklessly stored at
Biden's unsecured private office at the
UPenn Biden Center his home library and
even next to the special Corvette and
what he called his lock garage even
though we have pictures of the garage
wide open and as you can see that little
circle on the New York Post today it
shows the papers just laying there now
breaking this week the president of the
United States is under an investigation
are you happy a special counsel has been
appointed but you don't need an
extensive investigation to know that at
least one sketchy depraved self-serving
individual had easy access to almost all
of those documents and that would be the
president's deeply troubled and frankly
corrupt Sun zero experience Hunter who
made Millions with no experience he
lived at the Delaware Mansion where the
secret material was found now he listed
the home as his billing address for his
credit cards and his Apple account
according to the New York Post Hunter
even claimed that he owned the property
on a rental application at the very same
time Hunter was in the throes of his
crack cocaine addiction now he
frequently utilized the services of
prostitutes as we know from his laptop
from Eastern Europe and he had his hand
in numerous foreign business schemes you
know China Russia Kazakhstan Ukraine you
name it alongside multiple business
partners who are now in prison so quick
question does this seem like a safe
environment for classified top secret
documents I don't think so do you want
somebody like that having access to
America's Secrets now Hunter could not
keep track of his own handgun remember
he lost it and by the way or his own
laptop he forgot he put it in a repair
shop but was supposed to trust him
around top secret material look I'll be
honest I he's 50 years old we're not
talking about a child here but when he
went on Good Morning America and was
asked do you have any experience with
oil gas energy or Ukraine
nope why do you think they paid you all
this money Hunter I don't know he
literally said that uh maybe because
your father was the Vice President in
charge of Ukraine now maybe we know why
Joe Biden the quid pro quo withheld a
billion tax dollars until they fired the
prosecutor investigating his son being
paid Millions without that experience
look I wish I didn't have to talk about
Hunter ever again his life his career
his Investments his money his bills his
living arrangements are so intertwined
with his father as James Comer has said
and he is running the house oversight
committee investigation into the Biden
family Syndicate it is impossible to
separate the pair for example Kathy
Chung Biden's executive assistant from
his time as vice president was
reportedly hired after a recommendation
from Hunter and according to emails on
Hunter's laptop old Chung frequently
communicated with Hunter before enduring
her role as the vp's assistant now she
has since been questioned by law
enforcement as part of the investigation
into garage gate so how could Joe Biden
be this irresponsible remember that's
what he said about Donald Trump how how
did this happen uh but make no mistake
this is a massive Scandal and frankly
some on the left looked a little bit
shell-shocked a few of them even floated
A desperate conspiracy theory that the
classified documents they had to be
planted by Republicans maybe Donald
Trump himself take a look but you know
how
to me if you missing classified
information I don't mean to laugh but in
my house if stuff is missing
I know it's going to feel like apple
research to you does it feel like the
Republicans are behind it I'm suspicious
of the timing of it I'm I'm also aware
of the fact that things can be planted
on people I just happen to stumble upon
these classified documents I bet a trump
supporter put it there any amount of
money all right what you just heard is
insane it's pathetic to his credit even
Don Lemon at fake news CNN sees the
writing on the hand on the wall and
Chucky Schumer was not happy being asked
about it take a look
Senator I have to I have to get in and
to have to say this you you seem much
more measured about this than with the
Trump documents because you call for
transparency with the Trump documents
you want it lawmakers to have access to
the document seized from the former
president uh his residence in Florida
which it seems like you the bottom line
is I said that night it's premature to
comment on what should be done
yes for president Trump that's exactly
right I think that your spices are
consistent I sure do
all of a sudden no more hysteria over
classified documents from Chuck Schumer
because Democrats never really cared
about the Integrity of the classified
material for them it was all employed to
get Trump one more time but this is not
a game now I don't know what will come
from the special counsel investigation
into Biden frankly at this point I think
most Americans see we have a dual system
of justice I have very little faith in
the doj that they will hold Joe Biden
accountable they're in his executive
branch I don't think they'll hold him
accountable for anything his home
offices by the way and they've yet to be
rated even though they had no problem
doing it with Donald Trump and by the
way Donald Trump gave the FBI unfettered
access to that room with a classified
documents were they were in there they
could have taken them with them they
didn't they called and said put a
padlock on the door they could have come
back any day anytime but they decided to
go forward with the raid now I guess
that means means the house
investigations the oversight
investigation Jim Jordan Jim Comer
others are taking on a very high level
of new importance but that's not the
only critical task that is facing the
new majority a looming debt ceiling
Showdown is about to take Center Stage
so let me be very clear to the House GOP
you better be ready to hold your ground
this will be a big test the Senate
already screwed over the country with
1.7 trillion dollars at Omnibus Bill
they should have passed a CR they didn't
it allocates hundreds of millions of
dollars for gender Equity 65 million for
the preservation of salmon I like salmon
but not that much
nearly half a billion dollars for border
security
in other countries even three million
for B friendly highways you know
businesses honeybees and I can go on and
on but it's time for the house to force
concessions from Democrats bring our
budget under control stop robbing our
children and grandchildren blind and it
can't come soon enough big Banks they
are predicting a recession the housing
market is tanking inflation is still way
up according to CNBC 96 percent of
workers are now looking for a new job we
could be headed for real serious
Financial turmoil hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else